breeding some podcast Vil it's Thursday
the last [ __ ] day of the month so get
your [ __ ] together the Church of what's
happening now is brought to you by CBD
Lyon
listen pickin a [ __ ] reliable CBD
company was like [ __ ] pulling teeth
but lucky for you uncle four lucky for
you uncle Joey came [ __ ] through with
CBD Lyon
they make CBB Lyon from start to finish
and CBD Lyon has you covered
whether it's vape cartridges or shadow
or the tension there therefore you go to
CBD Lyon calm right now and check out
the third party lab results yourself and
on the way out pressing cold word church
and get 20% off your first order you
can't beat that nowhere and since the
summer is coming and Father's Day is
around the corner Toshi is back [ __ ]
wiping your ass with a dry toilet paper
that does not remove all this [ __ ] and
[ __ ] slime that comes out of your
filthy [ __ ] body if you got any poop
on any part of your body would you just
wipe it off with dry paper you filthy
animal disgust water cleans better than
dry paper my friends oh [ __ ] that's why
Toshi is here there a bidet to upgrade
your toilet or porcelain [ __ ] throne
fit for a king you understand me and now
they got the Father's Day bundle which
includes the tushy bidet the tushy
bamboo bump tiles made out of 100%
bamboo filters fibers to wipe your butt
dry and eliminate the [ __ ] hemorrhoid
juice and they got the cushy travel
because dads on the go probably have to
give it a little wipe from time to time
give him [ __ ] keep him clean
everywhere and that till she asked me
about your butthole t-shirt you know you
get you know you got sense and humor
from so all these items bundled together
bucked on a quarter but that's not what
I'm asking for what I'm asking like go -
hello - she calm right now take a look
at the fine line of a days they got with
a money-back [ __ ] guarantee they're
tremendous if it wasn't photo she my
[ __ ] would
smell like a [ __ ] dead camel thank
God - she came into my life especially
now with humility sets in your [ __ ]
and that [ __ ] tear gas of death comes
out yes so - hello - she doc calm right
now and press in church and get 10% off
your order delivered right to your
[ __ ] house
check this [ __ ] melee are you
[ __ ] nuts or what I mean that gets
you let you know you I forgot about the
song that's a great sound so great
sounds like 98 that's it that was right
before Big Daddy [ __ ] the Man of
Steel and seven you're 87 so what's up
Tarzan was so great that welcome all
made for the show first time I've known
Moses we were [ __ ] since he was a kid
that was an old man and I you were an
old man how long have you been don't
come before now professionally
twenty-year it'll be to June will be to
my 20 year anniversary
professionally yeah it's not the first
time I did stand-up was in 95 I was a 40
year old kid as well go do it in high
school was right after my father died
and I was skipping school and my English
teacher was like don't you want to be a
comedian she's again stop [ __ ]
skipping school to smart and let you do
stand-up in class and I was like no
[ __ ] brainer so she changed my life
that's crazy how a teacher I had a
teacher it's cut in fact I'm doing the
bald guy - August 10th and a friend of
mine calmly goes guess is going to see
on August 10th mr. Levite Oh mr. Lavina
was my sixth grade teacher amazed and he
made a deal with me shut the [ __ ] up
during the week and Fridays I'll let you
go up in class and do material and I
wouldn't even do material I would sing
yeah Frankie Valli so amazing like a
ruffle shirt on and I try too cruel the
girls and they tell me to get the [ __ ]
away from them you should get the [ __ ]
is a steal [ __ ] hilarious I used to so
I did like stand-up one night I was just
like in class I'll write the material
and do the stand-up and then I started
freestyling so I would go grab a little
jacket from from from wardrobe in the
theater department I'll come back to the
class and I'll do an impression of Chris
Farley and I would just roast the class
as Chris Farley I did that like several
times I I did three shows in one day my
Spanish teacher got me out of like three
classes that day so I could do all our
other class three shows in one day oh my
glasses it's amazing with teachers if
they really like pay attention their
students and they
and they push you and they drive you
they literally changed my life did you
go to college I didn't know I so let's
go him a long time ago headed into high
school right into right into right into
standing right what was the first club
you performed first Club was the last
stop the first comedy comes last time I
was sitting my mom forced me to get a
job I was running this [ __ ] flag
company sold flags and I was reading the
Houston Press on the back of it it said
Houston's funniest person competition
that the last time was the same day was
like the deadline was June 9th I was
like oh [ __ ] so I went and ran to the
comic of my buddy took me Nick we stole
my dear friend to this day that I grew
up with and cornea [ __ ] he was like you
ready was the first day the rest of your
life and it was we walked in I signed up
the list I learned about it the system
all there's open mics is what you do
baba and I was like oh my god all my
materials like gear to high schools I'm
gonna rewrite this [ __ ] and I went up at
the using funniest person competition
and actually Scott Kennedy was hosting
Sean rouse went up then I may they both
rest in peace man so there was both
those guys were there that night and I
started learning about staying up and I
went to the comedy showcase no there's
just evolution you got to really want it
what use is this it's 99 yeah I think
we're gonna say you won the competition
no no no no I made like the wild card I
was I was good like right at the gate oh
did pretty well right of the gate and I
made like the wild card thing or
whatever and then the next year I made
the finals then I realized that
competitions are just stupid and you
just need to go and work on your craft
and go on the road and you know Danny
Martinez at the Comedy Showcase took me
under his wing whoo-hoo also like
mentored Ralphie may and T shun-chan and
all these guys that came up the black
chick I mean the black yeah oh my god
Thea Vidale you have a dog yeah exactly
so many cats came out of there Shayla
Rivera as well it makes you want to cry
like it makes me want to cry yeah when I
think about what Houston meant in my
calmly life right like how big of a
scene and then I was one he used to was
like how much fun it said it really was
like you really but now Ralph he's gone
and Sean around cigars and half the
people I did comedy from that town
are no longer even involved in rally but
for a moment in time it was like the
Konami store
yeah I forget about Monday night's
Monday night oh my god that open mic was
amazing [ __ ] just you know for people
don't know like 99 98 to 2000 something
yeah Houston was my midway point right
because it was just a party yeah
absolutely it was just a party and it's
hard to explain the people what it was
like like I did come here like I would
go down there let's say I have a go
although I would book up [ __ ] froggy
bottoms oh my god froggy bottoms in
lubbock book you know Midland and Odessa
yeah yeah all these [ __ ] places in
Texas six weeks and had based myself out
of Houston I'd sleep on Jody's cow a
rancher who ever had a [ __ ] cow in
those days so Sunday Monday Tuesday and
Wednesday I'd be in [ __ ] Houston just
eating smoking no but days was the last
stop Tuesday's was there's like rudyard
right thing going on yeah there's the
the the Greek restaurant I forgot the
name of it was another place laughs stop
you want to cross the street to the
corner with Jodi Reds no no not right
dude yes yes [ __ ] but they locked surely
one day's is that yeah Tuesday's was
that [ __ ] definitely read news what
you're definitely the Greek restaurant
upstairs always Wednesday Wednesday was
the Greek restaurant on Wednesday night
so that Thursday was mussels
rapmon French rule and Pasadena Texas
you had company showcases black comfort
that started Beaumont oh that's right
cuz the first people who had that Club
were a nice black couple they were
engineers oh you know what I don't think
I ever met them 99 98
yeah I did Beaumont writing back there
Hylton in the back and slade ran out for
a hospital wait Rand and then they moved
it into a bank called a comedy Texas yes
that was a fun deed yeah is it really oh
no yeah goodbye for a week I would
basically go to Houston I would just fly
the he's yeah and then for a month
that's where I met you first use the
laptop was in the last glad never at
shake I still to this day remember a
lady used to I came out it's a walk in a
hobby airport [ __ ] mess Hobby Airport
is it's [ __ ] price too came up
praised me for liked when I said they
[ __ ] I got two dollars a match like
most I [ __ ] around you need to come
Mel a got Maz Jobrani over there [ __ ]
doing this thing you should come out
they [ __ ] bored out of the water with
the [ __ ] you're doing you're like come
on it's not [ __ ] waste your time I
remember to this day bro I've been
waiting for this moment to sit down and
talk to you about it for a really long
time
and the first time I met you met you was
really through Jody when you were doing
shows with Rogan and he was I think it
was like fresh off of like a few years
separated from Newsradio I think he just
kind of finished that running small kind
of starting to settle down after Phil
died and all that stuff it's been like
four years maybe at that point max I
think and then he was just getting in a
show fear factor and all that and that's
why I met you and we all hung out and
did it and you were like I'm leaving the
airport next day I was like you know I
gotta take Joey
so you pumped me up so much you like you
like made me want to be more aggressive
even my sandwich I was already insane
you know doing as many spots as possible
staying up till 3:00 4:00 o'clock in the
morning getting up and going to this
[ __ ] flag shop till I could get out
of it and start doing a full time but
you're a big motivator in my life and
I'm very happy that we actually get to
sit together and have this conversation
but it's just ketchup
if I came from a market in Denver where
there wasn't a lot hmm and I wanted to
[ __ ] and do stand-up right there's
nothing like wanting to do something and
being held back you know Boulder had
poetry readings right the comedy works
on a Tuesday which only gave you spots
a month and then there was a kid Jimmy a
beta that gave you love and there was
another guy on Saturdays that the show
started the laughing yeah and you would
love to drive and I will go up and tend
to yeah there's a little micro that's
very hard to comprehend at that point of
course so I was frustrated so I did one
of the other open mica does I became
acquainted with my [ __ ] car and and
put it in my mind that I had a drive to
do spots I would have to go like two
hours on a Tuesday to go to uh
what's-his-name through to I was knocked
how do you bomb up and yeah I would have
to go to Cheyenne Wyoming ami when I
went to Seattle there was just so much
action yeah I was gonna say your spend
time yeah contrast to where I was from
when I met you know you and I both know
this yeah there was that much the thing
that Houston had over a lot of other
cities was the support mmm the support
of the community at that last spot stop
it a night
I'm sorry I keep saying laughs pot stop
yeah a comedy showcase you know you
think of if you really sit down mmm I'm
not here to insult anybody no telling
you the facts yeah of course if you sit
down and you count the talent that was
the Houston 99 to 2000 it was
mind-boggling yeah
first of all you had to have a new 5
minutes every time you went on stage or
you would get tortured the comics if
you're not trying new [ __ ] all the time
Dave we taught you yeah the comics would
let curse torture the [ __ ] I mean a joke
yeah yeah what'd you do it three times
in a row yeah let's breathe a little bit
I feel like listening to open microphone
Aviv at first you want to strangle
somebody with what Ellen you is the fact
you feel left that joke three weeks ago
you should have worked on that in Conroe
right right or walking somewhere else
actually but here at the Open Mic year
Shelburne knew
five every [ __ ] week right so the
pushing was there
you had Matt Kirsch you had [ __ ]
Scott candles from used as well cocoon
is a beast you would imagine Scott
Kennedy being gay in that era and
talking about would that come from
Kimmage and you know I had that gay
neighborhood we with yeah monsters yeah
yeah he was the king of macho yeah if
you walk down Montrose to Scott Kennedy
yeah people would I still look in the
kitchen sometimes a missile walking what
is it yeah young soldier I'm gonna show
you how to get [ __ ] in the air you
didn't give a [ __ ] go right on the army
base and salute people who's in the army
no okay last time I saw him was in Iraq
he gave me a coin and I'll never forget
that it was like thank you he was a
great guy everyone saw you catch and you
have a little eighteen-year-old recruit
yeah confused some useless he didn't
really know look at me give me a wait a
hundred [ __ ] dick with his
rifle over his shoulder how I like it
under Prasad your person it was at first
open mic I was that he was hosting it
and he or he went up yeah he was hosting
it and he uh my buddy who's now like a
fright flight director at NASA you know
at the time he was 18 19 years old he
was like come on come over I'll suck you
think like you never suck your dick
before and my friend is tying his wife
but he just his face terik you majid at
that time he was doing that kind of
material in Texas like it was just it
would blow that me in the room would
just you can't follow him you couldn't
follow him he was being so powerful and
so crass and so but just had the like
the right touch and seasonings to be
able to get away with it too
it was just very funny to see a white
guy with a [ __ ] FUBU Jersey with the
way I was gonna ask with Scott Kennedy
then he said fubo it was he black
no he was white his white guy yeah who's
Jewish is like a chubby white guy with
with with a FUBU Jersey and I think you
had like a rainbow patch on and it was
hilarious it's like what are you doing
it it was so funny
he works for him he used to like I
thought even after I had been a regular
up if you have to know where you stand
in life when you have to know you stand
in comedy and I remember going on open
the first time I went to Houston I
opened for slate hmm and it was a hell
of a week oh yeah called women it was
[ __ ] crazy and then they talked me
into staying on Monday like you're not
staying mumbling no oh yeah anyway you
got a stay I say I don't know and
they're like [ __ ] stay that's a fun
man you're gonna [ __ ] be and white I
walk down and 200 people the [ __ ] 200
oriented 200 comma 200 yes there's so
many 60 comics we six like seven to two
yeah all these guys are trying you know
they really want to get into the laughs
stop and they would bring all their
friends and they would pack out guys
back Sam again great audiences yeah
[ __ ] $2 beers yeah yeah [ __ ] late
yeah Monday they for everyone listening
open mics in LA have zero audience zero
audience in most cases men most cases
open mics is like other comics are you
know sitting in the back that's it and
there's like one or two people in the
front I mean it's it right most of the
time it's crazy because there's like a
real room if you build an open mic as a
train wreck it becomes an open mic for
people enjoy right people don't really
want to go up and see 15 guys through
six minutes
they want to see a train wreck and
that's the aspect I didn't know about
open mics I learned that in Seattle
right Seattle's always big about that
Monday and Tuesday was a train wreck
right because you had people that
weren't comics you had a lot of hobbyist
exactly that were crazy in their real
life right they came in there one hand
come on Oh God those type of yeah yeah
yeah there's one guy we couldn't wait to
watch every time and everyone who's the
worst he was the worst I've seen his
name is Larry Simon he was a real estate
agent I'll never [ __ ] forget this guy
and I was like maybe you just have to go
filthy bro I don't know what to tell you
just be filthy and the next week I see
him on set and everybody's going nuts in
the room like what's going on and you
see Larry Simon talking about some
really filthy [ __ ] host of her ass you
know like it was awful who did the
horrible job executing whatever he was
doing I was like I don't think he really
understood what I was trying to
completely naked on stage last week it
completely took their dick out there's a
completely naked Doug Stanhope I think
did that one time I don't like yeah well
he also did it what follows week right
away or one that was way shaved head
waitress [ __ ] on stage yeah had a
waitress come up with shave his balls
and he was at the last stop the
following week and it was that Monday
night did it again he's just like I
forgot what's-her-name a waitress we
were just talking about it the other day
darn the waitress was it Dori it was a
Dora Dutton the girl from was a cute
dory doesn't shake that move to one
London yeah she's great always give you
asses [ __ ] but you never gave me that Oh
every time you bumped it was hit hold on
I have something here Audi's or [ __ ]
yeah
pills she was very scuse great energy I
just saw on Facebook couple days ago
their big girl what were we talking
about
duck stand all the last and no balls I
just told the story about her she was a
great kid
no she was a cute yeah cute and a great
kid and she moved here she got a job at
La Jolla
at the candy store but she also did
magic or was her father raised her in
the circus
well there's a she was raised in the
circus so she was very hip and then she
started getting some momentum with
calmly in San Diego she moved to New
York and she was kind of booking sounds
calmly hold this is hot like 2004 yeah
2000s 5 and then sounds close and came
out here and she came out with Sal but
at the time they were doing a show
called
magic with the Stars mmm
and she shot the pilot she was such a
great magician Wow
she ate fire and all that [ __ ] so while
they were shooting it then ABC picked it
up and they were gonna shoot magic with
the Stars where a magician teaches a
star magic while they were shooting the
pilot they put him up at the magic hotel
oh no she was kind of cute she was kind
of flirting but say anything bad but one
of the camera guys broke into her room
at night raped her in the middle of the
night what the [ __ ] if she had to press
charges in the news to show got
cancelled no more magic with the stars
[ __ ] ABC found out the hard way
magicians are creepy people who play yes
and [ __ ] game what was the cameraman
cameraman a PA something rapist you
gotta come back and go to court
holy [ __ ] ABC paid her off yeah keep it
hush-hush
yeah or they paid her money for what it
happened why she's I guess she ended up
suing ABC right on that point yeah she
lives in Idaho Shannon she has a husband
a kid amazing and somebody from LA moved
up to be with her like she was tight
with somebody right away a gay guy I
just forget it all started by shaving
Doug Stan's boss she lost that job right
at that comedy club he was very sweet
and very nice she always was she always
she liked dirty comments like this
because I mean come on [ __ ] swallows
fire I mean she's not gonna be heat I've
been thinking the last couple years I
don't know where to start I don't want
to step on anybody's toes and most
importantly I didn't want to hurt
anybody's feelings but I always wanted
to do a documentary of the houston
comedy scene and what it meant right at
that time because say what you want
about babbit that Club was on fire the
club was on fire he was the best and
worst thing that was right he was the
best and worst thing that happened to
all those kids yeah all those kids yeah
- I was seeing it - the the the thing
that I had I remember watching the
things unfold I was like I don't think
I'm gonna make much progress if I just
stay here like as a comedian and what I
want to do and try to accomplish and to
me that the comedy showcase was the spot
where you really got the work in
and you really learned it too and Danny
was very open and share with me he was
like gonna be my last student I feel
like you can I mean he really literally
is still alive yeah yeah thanks I see
Dylan he's doing great man he's doing
good you know he had a kidney transplant
Peggy gave him a kid might do something
that was really amazing and it took and
he's doing great but what he did for the
Houston comedy club scene like the
comedian's like really that took time
and went over there and and pushed all
their [ __ ] aside and really use that
room to really grow and everything he
taught me about the road and how to
build act he said you'll be a star in 20
years are you ready - are you I'm not
gonna waste my time if you don't have
that plan and I'm about to hit 20 now I
just got my Netflix special E he was he
was spot-on on everything that he taught
me like from technical standpoint to
what I should do and what I expect on
stage and all these things that you need
is a comedian all these tools you needed
as a comedian and that was like the best
thing that happened to me and Babbitt
was great for the comedy club scene and
bringing people in and bringing all the
acts in and really doing it but what he
did that he didn't understand was that
you can't take comedians that have a
really solid future and rush him and
take him to LA and take him to London
and there's one communion in mind that I
have been Mowbray he was really talented
a really brilliant guy and I feel like
you didn't he didn't give him a chance
to mature and and really you know grasp
what it takes to be a comedian and
before you put him up in front of all
these people and you you know in the end
Ebru in the club man see the movie
punchline I did yeah punchline it was
the movie I watched to make me pick up
the phone right
like I knew about comedy I knew I wanted
to do it I was writing material but I
just didn't know where to start right
punchline was the movie that made me get
up down I'm one for one one and see if
there was any comedy clubs in the area
and they're like become he works and
they gave me the number and I know I'm
beginning tonight and then six weeks
later I saw an ad in the paper I think
comedy class but my point being remember
the club owner in that I don't in that
movie he was a very with Tom Hanks
you're talking yeah with Tom Hanks and
those people that's a great movie to
watch if you're a
if you're starting out as economic
because that's what I thought I thought
thank you went to a club you reached on
to that order yeah and the owner gave
you guidance and he gave you real
guidance from the heart and he spoke to
you about what to expect and that was
Lina you have to cut through the
[ __ ] everybody wants to be a comic
right in my world show it to me
rags Esha I know exactly where you're at
doesn't even need to go see you yeah you
know how long you been in it 3m mark I
know exactly what you don't yeah I know
exactly what you're doing
what you feeling emotionally where you
think it should be you [ __ ] when I got
you I got thirty minutes but it's really
tell but it's calling me you know we've
heard it before you were there you walk
those steps yeah I didn't get that
guidance yeah you know I had the comedy
works when didn't have the time yeah
they tried Wendy did hire two people to
help comics which nobody else did she
helped the writer isn't to do a stand-up
little writing ring and then she she
hired a guy to put you on stage and
critique you you know but he was an
[ __ ] of a friend so then I went to
Seattle and Seattle's owner was some guy
we never met and Redbook was John Fox
but the guy that ran the club his name
was Carl and that was the closest I ever
had
so I mentored the comedy father he
walked you through the steps he tell you
to eliminate that joke right whether you
like that I get rid of it yeah we got
nowhere with it that's what Danny would
do you know that's they would do yeah
they would tell you not to go to certain
places right and you as an [ __ ]
wouldn't listen
yeah and then you come back with lumps
in your head one like I'll put you the
back of the line right exactly for that
was now you're the backup yeah well you
start listening yeah then you get to the
front of the line because everybody
knows more than you know you know and
Danny would [ __ ] stress me out like
on purpose
he would just be like for a whole year
like so many guys were opening and for a
solid year I've been doing you know all
these free spot you know it's not even
like feast buy all this training I call
it that's what it should be gone and all
this training I'm overly ready I got
like 20 bucks solid minutes I should be
open it you know I should
Hosting like I need to [ __ ] knows
he'd make me [ __ ] wait he was like I
want you be better than everybody else I
want you to [ __ ] want it so bad and
that's what he did to me you know and
that's what he would do come in Oh
Ralphy pops in i'ma put Ralph E before
you let's see what you could do tough
guy you know that kind of thing being
two years in the game oh you know what
you're smashing imma put you before
Ralph let me create a whole situation
between you two let's see how he does
and you do it and step it down he has to
step up his game and what he has to do
and he would play these he would do
these like training tools exercises and
get you to the point where like I'm
ready and I hosted for like a week and
then next thing you know I was featuring
and I featured like only like six months
and they said I was headlining really
quickly because of what he did to me and
what he forced me to do and edit and
take this out mic technique hey you have
a tool oh that was a matter with you you
know you gotta be conscious of that
you're not making eye contact you know
bring your audience in what are you
doing you have a wall in front of you
break that wall down talk to these
people look at them don't be afraid
don't shy away if you're afraid I'm
gonna be afraid they're not gonna think
you're real you gotta talk to them you
know that was so many tools that he gave
me to to to be able to do that and and
he took me as far as he could and gave
me all these tools to allow me to get to
a certain level and then Chappelle came
into my life and Chappelle became that
mentor was like yo this is what it's
like being here now this is the sick
this is the the things that could come
out of your life and and how you know to
navigate Hollywood and how to pitch
stuff how to you know how to how to
really like just it's like it's just you
know getting getting that information
that most people are not privy to and he
was able to like guide me through that
and still to this day you know so I'm so
lucky okay so I was doing so when you
asked me to go come to LA he's like you
should come to LA that whole thing was
like two thousand four or five I was
feeling so stressed out I was like I
really should make a move either LA New
York I got to do something and then I
joined a crew called Allah made me funny
there's these Muslim comedians that
started this tour and it was really
super ahead of his time and they were
doing really well I thought it was kind
of corny to be honest when I first heard
it I was like this sounds like some
Disney [ __ ] like I'm a real comic I grew
it you know I mean I'm growing up in
this comedy club scene I have this goal
and then I was like man
these guys are really working in there
were legit comedians and preacher mods
like tour with Lopez and wrote for Damon
Wayans and all these guys like hold on a
second Asura smart fresh guy I don't
mean to give it a shot so I joined the
crew and the next thing you know we made
a film we raise capital and and before
what's called for walling where you rent
out basically different theaters we did
a deal with like landmark and this movie
came out as a documentary concert film
and and and then Dave's family became
fans of our show and preacher Moss who
founded the tours also from DC there's
always like connections and then he came
out to our show when we had a tour stop
in Columbus and he Chapelle showed up
with his mom with his niece with his
brother and sister to watch a show and
then he surprised the audience at the
end of didn't our completely clean
killed we all had dinner that night and
Dave was always like man you know you
guys did this outside of Hollywood like
that's mind-blowing to me I'm a
Hollywood guy I've always came up in the
Hollywood game he you know he started
poppin off when he was in his teens and
he doesn't know anything outside of that
and he saw his touring venues you know
theaters all over the world like we did
they Apollo and love we did like 30
shows 28 shows in 30 days in England and
Scotland we were touring you know
Holland before people were touring it
aside from like you know Rhodes was up
there for a long time and then
Scandinavian region we introduced Doug
Stanhope to a promoter in Denmark to get
him like in 2007/8 start working there
it's very fascinating to see that in
South Africa as well Nelson Mandela he
was just really blown away but we're
able to do independently and that's why
I feel like I got my PhD and stand-up is
being a part of that tour and being able
to like go to go walk up on a stage and
just be clean you know just do an hour
clean and then go from there go to a
comedy club and be as dirty as I want
but that allowed me to add other tools
in my tool belt that I otherwise didn't
have and then Dave started making us
come back and then we just connected you
know just we were in the same city in
San Francisco he's like why don't you
guys come out and we were like hey man
let's get a picture with Dave you know
we walk in and and Dave's like oh man
Allah made me funny let me take a photo
with you guys it was like what it's just
like excuse me they didn't understand
or grasp what was really going on seems
like you want to open for me tomorrow
again so we other and I hope perform the
next day and then the next day and then
next you know we're not LAN I was like
come to Atlanta I was like Kappa be in
the same area like cool coming up you
know why won't you stay throughout the
whole weekend makes you know 700 shows
and he's introducing me for my special
six years later it's crazy but that's
how it really happened it's all started
how it's nuts you put the work in
oh yeah you by issues it was you know
you said summerlee that really I liked
the guy that read I like I like that
everybody was there I still enjoyed bad
but I'm happy he took me on some tours
or Paul Rodriguez he yeah absolutely
absolutely I was in a different place
you know I was just like I need to still
learn it was the best thing for me to do
that and he was like he was he was a
tough guy to crack if you were at that
age and where you were I thought he
overstepped his boundaries at some
levels he was doing a good job at what
he was doing yeah and then he was
promoting shows for Carlos he was grown
shows the rogue and he was blown from
brain show yeah he was killing it he
[ __ ] it if I they got into the comedy
business yeah he got into the County
business in a weird way and one of my
all-time favorite stories at the store
and I and he knows I like them and I'm
fond of them I'm the type of guy don't
say much to somebody you can't [ __ ] with
some of these dream ray exactly but I
don't say nothing well I'd rather cuz I
don't like people talking about my dream
anything else I'm fan of a drug guy
whatever you want to say it's not what
the Kombi dream [ __ ] you don't [ __ ] with
people's trade exactly even when people
come up to us a little take a look at
this tape tell me what you think I don't
say a word you know I got a really
really really really really know you as
a calm right and really know he is a
human being that when I tell you
something to mourn you're gonna do it
don't tell me to watch it and then we're
gonna keep doing your same [ __ ] over and
over
now you're lost exactly if you want my
[ __ ] opinion and I'm not gonna give
you much yes I'll tell you maybe we get
rid of that joke reg you separate the
audience there's always a little
something I loved when I was already a
regular at the store I had already
booked MADtv I decided I wasn't good
enough something I had to follow Victor
Paulo and all sandwiched in between Nick
DiPaolo and Doug Stanhope oh yeah Jimmy
I saw a level of professionalism and I
saw my level of professionalism break
and even though I lived in LA I said
this is my last spot that way we're all
on the road for 18 months I go down and
dirty
no eyeline feature every 50 a week 400
with a greyhound well you know what you
have to feel your own right oh yeah
so I know time B and I know everything I
knew that Ben Mowbray mm-hmm and one
Houston's funniest person funniest
person he had a gift of comedy and yeah
Jay he was a smart super smart yeah
smart guy you know he was doing Stanhope
and Stanhope was let them know it yeah
Stanhope was breaking his boy yeah he
was doing us a variation us yeah of
course but it was still an intriguing
yeah yeah try to be Stanhope and Hicks
and I get he was six months in the game
with six months looking nothing and I
was happy for him I saw Babbitt push it
yeah I saw Babbitt put him in position
but L know and I have 20 stories where
he actually Babbitt called had Linus had
said if you let him feature he's gonna
give you a hard time
Oh like I've had three headlines that's
coming at me go is he [ __ ] crazy he's
heard that Mowbray he's good but he's
not gonna put a dent in my oh no forever
so I'll never forget getting the call I
got the call one that cause I'm amazed
to host at the store right on Sunday
nights and I would introduced to show
the balloon i right no no no it was the
showcases for Mitzi Oh bitsy would be
there and I would bump into Mitzi and
she'd look at the list and go [ __ ] him
here's a guy with dreams for ten years
yeah at this ball shootin admits he look
at him front cam and I'm like what he's
wearing and I'd have to be the bearer of
bad time
yeah I have to go up to the guy go
listen Vince you don't want to see you
this week called Scott day or whatever I
still remember what's that I think it
was Corey who came down to me she goes
oh by the way you're putting up some kid
from Houston he's the new hot thing and
she was telling me I already knew and my
heart was breaking yeah it's terrible
because you're putting them in front of
Mitzi you're not putting them in a
you're on a TM yeah exactly
you're putting them in front of Mitzi
this is a lottery to make a break this
is a lottery ticket this isn't like a
career jump that admits he doesn't like
you you could come back in two years no
she's gonna remember this bombing or
this what I mean yeah
so Sunday comes they came in like Sunday
and what they eat like that [ __ ] la
cienega at [ __ ] the rib rib legs I
bury the drinking why babbit's got Matt
blades and Gersh oh yeah who's running
CAA
so funny he was my sister Nikesh he's a
crazy girl on the [ __ ] the wig yeah
the deal was to get Matt Blake to sign
Ben and take him to the wig and you know
get his career going
he's old Tommy's so [ __ ] he wasn't
even a year in he was a year or
something that he's featuring which
really ate my craw yeah yeah he should
jump you can't jump steps this is
something you got a fancy for three
years right give him 20 we see right and
then come see me and Dad maybe I mean 20
weeks of MC in here who's they through
Sunday exact that's eight shows a week
of learning bumps and bruises and
[ __ ] headliners giving you [ __ ] you
gotta do 20 that do 40 of those but why
some talk and then we talk about
featuring them we'll talk about feature
exactly so he was featuring him I'm like
this is not why no you know and he
wasn't doing bad as a Fiji at eight
in 20 minutes it's easy when you plug in
show up the gravity club those crowds
there and your opening or featuring for
somebody like Doug stand up okay go to a
[ __ ] place where nobody knows anybody
the crowd is just not even didn't even
want to come to see stand-up and I just
didn't even know that [ __ ] was going
under the bar man you [ __ ] get them
together
let's see your skill set now partner you
know let's see what you have now that's
what you miss little [ __ ] bar in the
corner that was common in front of the
door yeah every time somebody opened the
door they had to walk around here you'll
melt
yes my laces melt you're just sitting
here yeah lately the first time you're
20 is yeah two customers new just melt
it melt so now you play them like a
fiddle you like come here baby sit down
better than that I go to the [ __ ]
store Mitsy gives me the list she's a
one on board time baby
and I seen his name bow bend over bend
over bro I never forget there's very few
lights I'd forgotten at the store yeah
and that was one of them when I still
remember buying at the bottom of the
stairs and watching them come around the
side like they had Richard Pryor that a
posse Oh God the snack awake man you
know three young comics from Houston all
the people that lived in heat here now
from Houston the grant Whitehall it was
all about everybody and boozing having a
good time yeah and I'll never forget
that it was in the middle of showcases
leggo Mitzi I'm gonna put this kid up
he's the next Billings
oh-oh-oh you don't beat though I gotta
throw some fire oh yeah I'm not gonna
let you get away with yeah I got to
protect my mom yeah exactly yeah so I
went up to her very nonchalantly and I
go [ __ ] this is the kid from Houston
that showcase it they saves the next
Bill Hicks it might be worth your while
forget how look at that be gone for a
month next thing you know [ __ ]
babitch rubble to show this they're
walking upstairs you got this [ __ ]
bat Blake goes in the corner babbit the
three flunkies half of Houston's in and
he goes up this
up there with eagle yeah and he would
like the way you know they eat that
alive yeah yeah at those places like
though you can't walk your move is done
I said the [ __ ] had stayed sucked the
energy you can see it gone soon as he
hit the stage you crawl through three
jokes that work in Houston and you can
see the color one from his face yeah and
he continued and then she started
yelling get him off no it's my ass oh my
god and you can see him on stage and it
was like somebody hit a death man the
only thing that was holding him up was a
skeleton the only thing that was holding
him up dog was the skeleton that felt
bad yeah if you don't think inside
there's a human being and there's a
comic I felt bad you're wrong yeah I
felt horrible for him I felt any know
what it's like to be in that position
yeah where you get a little bit ahead of
yourself and you go [ __ ] what they say
I'm gonna go do this anyway and it's a
horrible experience and I'll never
forget him this is where I remember the
most was him walking off and nobody
saying nothing to Babbitt turned so
lonely [ __ ] him and he walked out of
there but he just wanted to leave yeah
that's all I'd want to do was leave yeah
and as he was walking out like you know
how he walked up with everybody around
them he walked out there he was ten feet
behind them thought it was the coldest
thing that's ever seen in my life
that's really the next night he went to
the improperly I'll get okay yeah but
the damage you can't do their damage is
done I remember when he came back to
Houston and he told me about what
happened and and he was just like you
know when I was sitting back there I was
like you and start thinking about that
stage all the greats that have been on
it and he just cried it just crumbled
yeah you can't do that psychologically
somebody it's not his fault they
shouldn't have done that I mean you know
he could he could've maybe try to stop
him do so young as early 20s I think at
that time the [ __ ] is gonna stop this is
where Babbitt and I like and also at the
same time I would say that you know
we've all experienced failure on a big
level on different levels and you know
different tastes of it and you either
want it bad or you don't either this
thing is gonna define who you are you
know
for successes like I remember when I
[ __ ] did this was a huge mistake yes
am I gonna wait this through another 10
years you know that's something do you
want it bad enough I am for me there's
nothing else that I wanted there's zero
broke no car [ __ ] break down whatever
it is you just have to do it if you
really want it you can't let those
things break you unfortunately it wasn't
the right support group and I and I
would see that as a young I remember
being a kid looking around going I'm not
gonna get better here you know this is
not the spot the last stop for me at
that time this is I don't have the I'm
not given the time and I'm not gonna be
able to get it here I need to go on the
road I would come back from you know Jim
holder would give me dates and we would
tour and do all these [ __ ] one-nighters
I would come back and rush to do the
blue show on Sunday and that's the spot
he gave me and he was like why weren't
you here I scratch you off the list I
was like why did you scratch me off the
list he says why were you here on open
mic on Monday I was like I'm on the road
I'm trying to get better I'm doing these
open mics this is where Babbitt would
treat me a little bit harsher you know
because I was younger or whatever and
whatever the thing that he had going on
he had going on but I appreciated what
he did for the comedy scene in Houston
I appreciated but he was bringing these
quality names and they were coming in
and we got to see you know Louie CK
before he even became a yeah I mean I
mean everybody damn road [ __ ]
yeah amazing co-headline [ __ ] amazing
people will not forget like that was
like 97 yeah and that was like 97 I saw
it in 99 mm yeah and then we would go to
that crazy hotel like the whole
experience
yeah was crazy yeah that hotel Willie
Nelson stayin yeah yeah and then the
flooding and this go if the only hotel
that you could check in to do a bunch of
coke on the water then oh man I need a
beer oh my open your hotel room and walk
ten ten minutes there'd be somebody
drinking a beer man well I just want to
say like I love Bette Mowbray I loved I
thought he was very smart funny guy he
had it he just really wanted and I think
it just wasn't fair what happened to him
and
it's just all respect but always know
it's all refer back to these this one I
tell people you know there's no book you
could read this it yeah you watch
exactly you keep your mouth shut you
give them the rope and you watching me
to hang themselves yep
Dave the hang themselves or they do
something with it right and even if you
hang yourself you still got plenty of
life left found myself yeah 18 times I
start example yeah you know I'm immune
to bombing because I bombed so many
times yeah it doesn't matter their mom
okay know what I did this I love I love
bombing getting in the car and knowing
exactly what you did to bomb yeah I know
exactly at the bomb I opened something I
came out too cocky yeah I should have
said that word the first three minutes
there's always something that man's
reflect on the bomb and you go all
bombing doesn't affect me at all no it
makes you better it makes you better as
long as you know that yeah as you're
getting in your car and you give that a
little giggle yeah I mean the best thing
to watch is it can be the funniest thing
you watch as a convenience watching
another comedian die on stage and the
reason why is that that's something that
you relate to so in a ly so personally
that it makes me personally just laugh
so hard because you have that experience
and nobody knows it better than a
comedian or a performer they just
completely dies on so you just laugh
because you were late to it so hard it's
not because like oh I'm happy he's
bombing no no no it's like this what
he's going through his mindset all the
[ __ ] this code it said the
catastrophizing the [ __ ] scene the
breakdown in the middle of the road he
can't get out of it he's looking for the
light have I been lit yet that [ __ ] is
like classic man first tree is a used to
break chair I used to break bottles I
hit a pigeon with a car oh my god I mean
when I bomb that we get so I have to
learn how to bomb with grace right that
was the big problem I had the first
three years the other thing that I had
to allow other comics than happens I
know when I bomb
but don't worry the same time on stage
ago I going oh god the [ __ ] is well the
worst you deny I destroyed that room
you're like I was sitting in the back I
had to take it to me though from a guy
just about it [ __ ] hit you hit me
with a slingshot easing you're telling
me that's the other retardation yeah you
don't want to say nothing I can't I love
what I bomb and you're standing there
having a drinking you all make nice to
break the eye contact I go how bad was
that bomber yeah makes the Gulf War look
like a [ __ ] Chinese parade because
that's the thing that were you around
with Ralphie fell through the stage that
smell buying this no I was not I was
back there I didn't know he fell through
the stages fell by I knew he fell down
the stairs at the last spot and that was
his big beef with the owner at the time
no and they were like I think he sued
him in something right he sued two
people he felt through he felt through
the stage it was like I heard I haven't
seen him at his peak when he first
started by whatever told me that he's to
have to lean up against the wall cause
he was like 700 pounds yeah he was big
when he first start big you seven big
went through the floor it spelled by
Insane for three books I just say a word
for that fool for three pounds my god
and then when they spelled buying this
was still open it was to the town when I
met Ralphie was to telling their spell
buying this and he was staying with Joey
Medina and already broken host [ __ ] Joey
did he broke his [ __ ] what do you call
those things the Japanese futon
the food broke his futon Mike and it
couldn't get it back up like when you
went to Ralphie's because you couldn't
cook them you couldn't pick the futon
back up like the back yeah well they'll
forget like I was hustling calls one day
you know like I'm just working for a
screw company out highbaugh I would
to get there for the morning and some
screws to people on the East Coast and
then it from there we go to Ralphie's
house for breakfast I'd rap like that
nine-member call a man one day and just
calling the lab spot I didn't know who
download it was I didn't know Danny was
and I don't know forget Colin spelled by
the lid yeah yeah lid was her name yeah
I would card out of the one yesterday
whistling Carlisle you remember that
miss Karns uh Joe Diaz I'm gonna I'm a
regular at The Comedy Store
I'd like to come down and do feet short
and right away she goes are you friends
are Ralphie and what do you think of
somebody sister made you friends of
mouth yeah but if it's a club owner yeah
yeah friends of the Ralphie she goes
well friends around for your welcome
here have a good day she hung up on
blonde no I didn't know a Ralphie had
done I asked something oh you don't know
he fell through the stage then he soon
oh my god so one day we're Ralphie's for
breakfast it's quiet and it's quiet and
I'm like you know I called Len cons it's
spelled by this master for a week Oh
work he wouldn't give me a week Oh work
if I pay for the whole that you felt now
just think about that that was the
intent I mean here's the sad thing about
traveling I know
ten guys in Houston personally I had 20
times more talent and could out joke me
any day in the [ __ ] week that's what
pisses me off about Houston and that's
why I went off on you that day about
opportunity yeah when you live in a
market that you could be out 14 nights a
week even though there's seven yeah I
want you out those 14 yeah yeah exactly
how's economic I don't want to hear
nothing me like you're gonna be saying
it's enough here now you need to move
get the [ __ ] out there's only so much
you could do with a market and then and
you're not Patel when you're trapped
yeah you can be trapped in the market
after a year and don't stand
up and not knowing yeah absolutely you
in my case I was trapped I was trapped
in the dancer I didn't think there was a
world outside it then and then I started
hearing about these different comedy
scenes when you travel people tell you
man come to Houston they just got ya
Dave would tell me all the time I would
be like man I think the next big things
and come out of used to all the time you
tell me like the next always thought the
next comedian the next there's so much
talent out there there's so much to pull
from you screaming John Wessel
encounters the murdering who's helping
up the job West all that rips of [ __ ]
you over Illya yeah he is usually roused
oh that's [ __ ] crazy man could kill me
I was a murdering cause problems
absolutely you know they had the other
kid there was another kid down there was
a phenomenal writer
I just ball right Ozzy was really gonna
hurt me I just bumped into Sarah tower
man oh my god you're great I'm yeah I
bumped it about biggest staff yeah he's
which I was very happy and got up and
got out because finally it's just so
much you could do it Amaro absolutely I
always told people sit still shut your
mouth Yeah right
but what do I leave you don't you lead
with the club all that says to your mom
that's what happened to me every night
go home I've had mine you walk to July
Valentine's Day yeah Memorial Day
weekend
Thanksgiving Day Christmas and New
Year's Day you've destroyed every
headline and a concert were here
I really can't have line yet cuz you got
no credits yeah now you gotta make a
decision that's the ideal situation and
I was at a real crossroads when you told
me that for me was just like hey I want
to be I want to be so [ __ ] ready you
know my whole thing is that I want to be
so ready that I want to terrify people
when I get like that's my own thing I
want to be so prepared I have to be
undeniable
you know I'm Muslim I'm Arab I'm a
refugee I have a citizenship by
Palestinian I'm I have all these things
all these stigmas on me I have to be so
good that's all I thought about and I
was like yes Joey I hear you and
something that my gut was telling me
just beep H it just be patience as a
marathons of 20-year since you
agent for overnight success that's why I
kept having in my head loop around and
thank God for the relationship with you
know although maybe funny like really
touring that understanding what a global
marketplace is and doing those theaters
and getting those repetitions and coming
back and building it back up and then
you know touring with Dave those years
so many years and still you know popping
in together and him you know being such
a big part of my life and like a brother
to me and then when I got into the
cellar I was like 17 years in you know I
mean some mothers like it we've heard of
this guy kind of like what's going on
and then you come in and you're just
like I have an hour and a half of [ __ ]
that's special ready that I'm gonna
rotate and I'm gonna murder every
[ __ ] set and that's where I want to
came come in and sure enough I came in
boom it went very fast everything was
going really well
tons of I was doing she was giving me as
he was giving me like 10 a night on
Friday and Saturdays as much as you can
do plus the comedy I miss she's been at
that yeah the always the yet no there
was the underground around the corner
and there's that oh my god why am i
blanking out there's a music spot right
around the corner and you do that
downstairs boom you hit it up 75 bucks
in front of a crowd that expects a band
get the [ __ ] out of that do a spot at
the cellar boom go around village
underground then go upstairs go to fat
black pussycat I mean working so hard
and then Derrick Trump should happen to
me where I sat next to him on the plane
turn that into a joke
boom colbert heard about it they came
out they watched me they flipped until
once you get on Colbert BAM we're on the
stone ten comedians to watch oh [ __ ]
next thing you know I'm you know I got
multiple offers for my specials now
we're cooking and that's what I wanted
and the only thing I felt like after all
that stuff happened was relief I was
like thank God it was right it's fine
are you very populated I I was always
calculated in my growth and how much I'm
learning and doing it and always like
not putting money first money was like
the last thing that I cared about it's
the number that's a mistake I make I
cared about me ask you are you making
any money no for so yeah they'll say
well why are you doing this I wouldn't
do it if I didn't get paid well then go
boy [ __ ] so Isis lied about like my mom
was like why you driving 12 hours for a
hundred bucks
teller 300 I would lie I would go to get
into that Club in Birmingham Alabama
what does he called are the stardome so
I drove 12 hours there boom do that set
drive back on the way home I stopped at
I stopped at the casino Lake Charles
play poker I was like whenever I get to
300 I'm gonna get out of here knows 19
it wasn't even legal to be in there but
you could just walk in they didn't have
the little IDs and all that [ __ ] you
could check it I would just wait play
poker get up to 300 bucks leave cash out
so I can when I come home I can show my
mother look look like I made 300 bucks
you know that's good and I could show
her that because you would ask them to
see what they paid you let me see what
you're doing she was worried about me
courting as any parent should be I get
it but she didn't understand stand-up
and all that so I had to do like all
these things all these extras to make it
look like I'm doing better than actually
am to show her that you know I am making
some growth and there is a career here
and things like that
oh my god my mom didn't really
understand like what I was doing
fully until she saw me with Dave at
Radio City Music Hall with chance the
rapper and John Stewart and these guys
in front of 6,500 people and she just
saw her son just do his thing on stage
just I had a murder and that's where Jon
Stewart and I became friends and that's
like the only celebrity to an Arab mom
it's like gameshow hosts and Jon Stewart
you know like that's it that's a 9/11
yeah it took 9/11 to expose Arab based
comedy right like you know you had your
thing I know that Mars right those guys
yeah that acts of evil yeah and they
were doing great with it but it took
like something that tragic of course
yeah blow it up comedy yeah you know how
[ __ ] crazy is that right my brother
would look me in my face he thought my
career was over he was like your career
is over because nobody wants to see it
Muhammad on stage telling jokes I looked
at my brother was like Omar you're a
pilot [ __ ] you talking about you know
you got a career you're gonna be fine
you know like it's gonna be fine so I
just like this is gonna be the big thing
for me and I've always had it in my mind
do it what was this thing that was
inside the evils that was forcing you
not to fail like we all have these like
when I work for my brother-in-law's
roofing company yeah well I took that
job the night before I drove my brother
was roofing company
I had a really thin card I got into
sleep all night and I said okay here was
my mother told me once that when I was a
kid my mother got mad at me once she was
when you got older I don't care what you
do
I don't care what you do you clean
toilets clean toilets it's a job if you
sweep sweep but make sure you're the
best at what you do well let you try
hard to be the best at what you do you
know when I got the job with my brother
loves roofing company when I was a kid
you know I knew one thing that for me to
work for him I had to be the best work
around that jobsite because I never
wanted somebody to go to him and go hey
you're [ __ ] brother-in-law's a
[ __ ] rare and I have a one attempt so
I knew that I had to be there at seven
even though the job started at 7:30 I
would be there at 7:00 and if the job
into the 4:30 I'd be there 5:15 well ice
whip you know I did things they didn't
even ask me to do right it's just the
same way you felt about comedy a hundred
percent even more so just coming here
just knowing that you know fleeing a war
in Kuwait seeing my mom and dad lose
everything
losing my father it's just like all
these things that I couldn't control
right happened and it felt very much how
you lost your father when you moved here
correct I lost my father like yeah about
four years after we moved in he didn't
come until he couldn't get it because
you know like the dad's got to do
everything I'm gonna finish up the
paperwork here living in a war I was
gonna baby yeah so it was was born in
Kuwait left Kuwait after the first Gulf
War in 1990 about three months into it
and then my mom got my sister oh you
remember shell I remember everything
about it oh boy details about it I mean
everything for when the when the Iraqi
soldiers came in and it was just a quick
takeover and it was a big robbery more
than anything like you didn't hear much
like as far as like the shooting and
then what have you I didn't I wasn't
like fully part of that I was part of
the chaos so Saddam Hussein like dropped
off all these guys that were imprisoned
and told them to just robbed Kuwait
it was a big robbery there's a massive -
robbery more anything else his dispute
was that
quoits been stealing from us for years
you know what I'm taking over quick
quakes actually rock anyway [ __ ] you
this is mine it was all political play
but forget it I was just a Robin yeah
well they come to the house and smacking
you and they were trying to so they came
into the house the first time the day of
the invasion they took over the whole
neighborhood because the neighborhood
was owned by the Kuwaiti oil company who
my father was employed by so that was a
really strategic point for that military
so they were there and then they took
over the whole situation once they find
out we're Palestinian they backed off my
mom told me they were gonna throw a
grenade into my room they were gonna
like they were going to do something
that she stopped they stopped them they
talked him out of it
and like my dad was just all about feed
these guys feed them they're hungry they
just came off the war from Iran they're
starving they're here to steal because
they're hungry so we fed them my mom and
dad would feed them they would come over
to the house in the morning they would
take all the food they would eat and
then we just leave they would leave us
alone my father was always worried about
his daughter of course God forbid she
gets raped or something happens and the
[ __ ] that goes down during war he was
just being very protective for that and
he paid the ultimate price for it man he
was like stuff I found out years later
he was like kidnapped my mom had to like
pay a ransom to get him out it was a
really intense time for my family now I
felt it they didn't tell me everything
but I felt it and I ended up in Houston
I was nine that my brother took me to
change you know just kind of change the
vibe a little bit so he took me to watch
the Houston Livestock Show rodeo you
know every year they have that joint
with all these big headliners and that
year was co-headlined by the band
Alabama that I went to and Bill Cosby
I saw Bill Cosby on stage I was ten in
front of 67,000 people at the Astrodome
and he's just murdering and I was like
what is this art form that allows you to
sit in a chair and speak in this little
tiny microphone this lapel mic and just
kill a whole crowd not just control him
with your voice and storytelling I am
I'm gonna do that look at my brother's
like I don't be a comedian he was like
yeah yeah you know he's like oh I'm glad
you're having a good time I was like no
[ __ ] do not understand I just
found my destiny [ __ ] and that's where
it came down to the I guess why I
figured out I was gonna be a comedian
and then two years later my dad came and
then he passed away shortly
that it was a she really really crazy
time for me man it's really really crazy
that's how I sigh didn't even know who
Bill Hicks was who Sam Kinison was I
didn't know the rich history that
Houston had and stand up I remember I
was doing open mics like eyes guys hey
he sounds like sam Kennison oh my goo
the [ __ ] is Sam Camus this guy was like
what do you mean you don't know sing cos
you're not copying right I was like I
don't know the [ __ ] Sam Kenny says I've
been here [ __ ] eight years a kid I
don't have cable were poor [ __ ] what are
you talking about the [ __ ] cats he
was like don't say this out loud again
came back the next day I can't remember
this man's name but he was an open mic
you know older guy just kind of
hobbyists and he just hands me all these
cassette tapes of all these HBO specials
and all these Hicks specials Sam
Kennison and and got John Mendoza as
well and all these guys that it came up
that I can't and and Dana Carvey and all
these things I just watch and I was like
oh my god that's amazing and I really
started understanding standing up and
watching Carlin and doing that because
then you didn't have all YouTube we just
pop in and let me see who the hell what
the history of stand-up is that you have
to like learn it from the street huh and
that's what it was so fighting me
because guys were like oh this [ __ ]
guy is just trying to be this these guys
trying to be that I'm like I don't even
know the guys he's talking about
they're like Eddie Murphy delirious he
did that joke I was like who the [ __ ] is
Eddie Murphy delirious yeah I'm not
gonna know that I had to catch up
culturally right you came here as a
little kid you don't have that history I
don't have the older brothers watching
these tapes and you know what I mean I
have older brothers but they weren't
watching that they were all going to
college and I was in a little country
called quake the only thing I knew is
that my sisters loved what is it blue
what is it a sitcom with a Cybill
Shepherd and moonlighting yeah it was
like that's it that's all I know
America's moonlighting and the Lakers
and the Chicago Bulls silently that said
the boss is out that's how I knew about
America and football this thing that you
throw so I had no I had all this stuff
to catch up culturally so it was a
really interesting was really difficult
for me especially being that young and
not having all this information and all
this stuff lying around and like you
know what I need to learn and that's why
the showcase was that place for me and I
would go back to places rough explain
some of the people your premier club but
the
was the last spot black stop yeah
because they brought in the Mitch
Hedberg Rogen's and sure Gaffigan x' and
all that then you had the middle level
club which was it's the showcase
showcase would be like the definitely
the one after they would call it like
the beat club to beat because of the axe
I would bring in their touring season
comedians headliners very [ __ ] funny
not very funny
these are guys that drug problems yeah
already failed TV yeah body of this show
fan exactly that still remains fun one
is shot like Michael Reid is somebody
I'll never forget he's so [ __ ] funny
man may rest in peace crazy was the head
of the last spot or thought I had more
vegas-based absolutely comics that went
to Vegas now played Vegas so you should
had a great variety absolutely to watch
and learn customer bleep not Dana Carvey
but the guy that writes for The Simpsons
being like at the lab stop and a wide
spot and Simon I just know the biggest
writer the probably that came out of
Houston at that time said tee shot
Shannon and the Shannon brothers tee
shot was like well hey I don't I don't
know but I mean Charlie died I don't
know about five sleeve down more than
that about ten years ago I think someone
that they were interesting we were eight
they were so was charm that T Shawn
wrote force animation rule for like vibe
and he had like he was he he flipped it
on writers do they go from one job to
the next
I think SNL was as long as I think it
was like a head writer ass enough like
ten years he was there for quite some
time right yeah that's right you just
got out and I think after his brother
passed were these to do a t-shirt you
know a Shannon family Christmas every
year at the laugh stop and you know the
last stop going away and then Charlie
dying it just kind of I'm pretty sure it
affected t Sean significantly since
that's what they get together and
Charlie was just a very sophisticated
stand-up he was really really good at
what he did and it might may he made it
look so easy but he was really really
good and he loved going up at the end
and he would freestyle like nobody else
and he was really talented
and yeah so that he was like the guy T
Shawn was the guy that was like oh man
you can like make it in the writing
world you can actually accomplish things
and get things going and do that and
also uh since then that managed steve
harvey for a long time to Rochon sean
mcdonagh think he was like the producer
guy he was just like produced everything
like oh you can make it in different
parts of Hollywood and then seeing
Ralphie obviously make it and do it and
you're like oh this is very tangible
it's very possible if you just work hard
and put in the time and effort but yeah
so Ralphie was a big time Danny Martinez
guy yeah yeah absolutely they're very
vocal very he loved Danny absolutely
Danny you know Danny had taken him on
the road for the first time at that time
fiha David oh yeah had made it was a
monster monster and she made Huston
proud like Houston was very proud like
he is a great example because they gave
her show on ABC that wasn't really Theo
you know I mean it wasn't like it didn't
really you know show who Theo was at
that time and they made her into like
this family friendly loving mother well
she is a loving mother of course but
she's just more crass and just more
honest and upfront and I think that's
why that show did what it did she had
too much too fast at that point but
she's like by far still surprised to
this day I haven't seen her do stand-up
a long time but she's a power she's
unbelievable she's unbelievable and I
remember Danny telling me the story when
she walked into the comedy showcase and
she was like I'm funny
put me on stage and Danny's the type of
dudes like oh yeah [ __ ] fine I'll put
you on let's see what the [ __ ] he got
cuz he you know most people think is so
easy they go up and they eat [ __ ] and he
was like fine he put her on and she
slayed she murdered the goddamn room the
first time she ever went up on stage
ever
he was like holy [ __ ] she's a superstar
Danny was the kind of guy that would
watch a comedian and most commuters
would like oh this person's not funny
not very good and he'd be like no he's
gonna make his day because watch watch
no I don't even give me time is like
he's not my student or she's not my
student and she's gonna she had Jenny
what's-her-name Jenna
it's her name she always had a notebook
on stage my god she was just had a
really successful acting career black
hair what's her name Jenna will come to
me but she was like everybody like she
was a hipster comedian before hipsters
and all that should happen and Danny was
like walked up there like you're gonna
be a big star and sure enough she
freaking became a very successful
community an actress he just had that
about him they would just like to see
guys and the people that would listen to
him did very well mrs. honor if you
really wanted it and you listen to Danny
you were gonna do something if no how
old are you we had this talk that night
I was like 23 stop Wow yeah so that was
15 years ago
no well 40 years from age of us it's
really weird that I'm really like I
don't tell comics this but there's a lot
of comics that when I see I feel warped
I feel very proud to have known them
because they really inspired me and
you're one of those guys like you
there's like 20 guys that I still
remember hanging out like well if going
like you're like okay yeah the next time
you go there the emcee right then the
next time you go there the feature ever
and then next thing you know they're
opening for you or something you're like
you know what he's doing a great job and
it's it's amazing that they stayed in
the game you know Lucas with Ramos you
see these kids and you know you've
gained a lot of success there's people
and they're still struggling yeah I have
no idea the amount of respect
I give them because I don't know if I
wanna quit mine now yeah I know
you ever see quitting as an option like
hey man I couldn't noway after the first
year yeah I knew I had too much time
invested I was already in yeah that's it
already said that I'm gonna get these
five I'm gonna get these things it's
kind of happen you can't see it right
now fine that's not yours
your job to be able to visualize what
I'm talking about what I what skill set
I [ __ ] have deep inside me and what
I'm able to do you'll just see let me
just keep sharpening this knife let me
just keep getting tight let me just get
right and get smarter you know get
better more experienced it's just like
watch just watch just whatever they
doubt of core but freaking had times
were just balling and [ __ ] in the
back of whatever I remember I remember I
was in Japan and doing this tour and I
was just reading before I was just like
having the spiritual moment with myself
and I'm just like crying I was like
please God tell me this is I did the
right thing please tell me please I know
I feel it in my core these people are
talking I hate hearing these voices
please you know oh he's not gonna make
it so hard business what are you
thinking you could be a great
entrepreneur you're smart big you could
be a smart businessman you could do this
you could say so tell things why are you
wasting your time like no this is for
the culture you understand I'm Way ahead
of the curve I know that's please please
let me buzz right and then I hear the
comic next door [ __ ] just oh I was
like god it made me laugh I was like
that's I'll take that as a sign I'll
take I'll take that as a sign do you
think that the hard work and the ethic
you have is from the immigrant mentality
and what you saw is probably not part of
what yeah it's definitely a big part of
it it's like you got to work harder than
everybody else I feel like you have to
work harder than everybody else to me
it's like it's like boxing hey man I got
a match coming up this [ __ ] I think
he's working on a 3m I need to get up
what am i doing sleeping I'm that kind
of guy and I can't stop thinking anyway
so I think it's just something you're
born with as well either you have it in
you to sit through it and deal with all
the [ __ ] and go through it or you
don't you know it really is and you
always feel like quit I always say like
ah man when I get to this number ah man
I just [ __ ] it I'm done you know thirty
years that's it I'm gonna put it in does
get some shows under my belt five
specials you have goals in my head like
this is what I want it's one
accomplished poem when I hit this number
but who the hell knows it's part of who
we are like how can you not go up on
stage I get low a little bit you know
the lows are low where you're not on
stage you're not working or you're just
not putting it like what am i doing
it's got to find a way to channel the
energy somewhere else maybe I don't know
the thing that's crazy for me is for me
I never want to let my friends down yeah
I never want to let the people down that
gave me 30 bucks to get the sacks down
exactly I didn't want to let the people
down and let me crash in the house right
people who put antifreeze in my car
absolutely more for me to make it for
the next town like I always what I
always had doubts on comedy I didn't
think about money or star now I'm
already in poppy I didn't you ever [ __ ]
about that I just didn't want to sell
drugs I'm gonna stop being a criminal
but most importantly it was for all the
people that did something for me to get
to where I was that you know this
morning I got out but I called one of my
early the guys that took me on the road
after three years you know and it wasn't
the ideal Road situation he didn't bring
me on the road because of my comedy
talents all right
he brought me on the road cuz he's never
driver's license there I was of the car
that was nice and clean and I would pick
him up on time and he would make me stop
at a liquor store and empty half the
Gatorade and I'd be driving he'd be
preaching yeah you know maybe I'd be
driving and he'd be preaching that's it
and then I get there in the first show
he give me 20 minutes
and if I hate a bag of dicks the second
show he go seven seven I don't know
where because no matter what he's doing
with his life I'm still representing
yeah absolutely I'm still he's still
working I thought the same way when I
did my special I put you know the people
that meant to me and up gave me they
were part of that story in the special
as well like Olivia Arrington even
Carolyn Picard you know Danny Martinez
don't learn I have them all in there
like that's all part of my story and the
people that I the thing that drove me to
not to quit is my mother like I have to
do this there's no other option I'm too
deep I can't get out of the seven years
in 10 years in like no it can't I just
can't be the rest of my life I'll be
thinking what if what did I do
Belle too early this and that I just
can't do that I have to the driving
force was like gotta get there got to be
successful had
to support my mother have to support my
family this is all I have in my head
like this it said I can't I will till
the wheels fall off Ralphie
all the time all the time because
Ralphie and I had a very interesting
relationship there's a ten-year gap
between us number one he was Danny's
like prized you know mentee right he
went off and they're very successful and
started popping off and doing things and
also it's got to feel a different way
when Ralphie comes in who's this young
[ __ ] kid you know what I mean what's
he doing or Danny's mentoring this kid
let me see this is all this like it was
like brotherly rivalry loving like
rivalry that happened and I was always
like hey what's going on we learn from
you kind of thing and he was like do I
trust this kid do I not trust this kid
kind of mentality and then next you know
it grew like oh it became it became
loving and he cared and he remember he
he gave me a ton of [ __ ] one time we're
at that Greek restaurant and I was
hosting and I've been doing stand-up
like professionals for like a month and
I'm wearing shorts and he's like the
[ __ ] you don't wear short he just ream
me I was like he's mean but I think he
has a point
so I didn't right out the gate and I'm
so happy that all a lot of years went by
and a lot of really great things and he
always monitored where I was doing and
he would send me love on Twitter he just
send me messages and send me love so I
was really really happy that when he was
in Houston and I happened to be in town
at the same time I went and drove to see
him I was like I have to see him because
I had a dream that what that we didn't
get to talk they properly talked and and
and he passed away and I was very upset
I was like I didn't get to speak with
him I was like [ __ ] this I don't know
why I had that dream at that moment
obviously you see way things happen now
I'm very grateful that I had the
opportunity to go drive to the Improv go
talk to him I was like listen you know I
was I was a kid I'm immature I hope you
if there's anything he's like there's
nothing what are you talking about I was
like I just want to tell you that it
means a lot to me to see you be
successful and to have this and to work
so hard to get to these accomplishments
it means a lot because it tells me that
it's very doable hoping that they gave
me it gives me a lot of hope and and I
appreciate that and it was all love and
he was having a good time was
somewhere heads for shrooms or whatever
so the conversation lasted a good you
know five seven minutes where was like
really focused between us I gave him a
hug give me a salt line and say hello
maybe might be like I just it was
interesting to see what happened like
how I had that dream and I was driven to
go talk to him and then he passed away
like a year and a half later serious
letters really crap I'm so thankful man
I'm so thankful because that [ __ ] would
have been in my heart forever open like
ah [ __ ]
had that dream I pushed it out don't go
I didn't man up go have a great
conversation with him like your brother
just one let you know that another this
means a lot to me the success I'm having
now you're part of that success because
you showed me with all kinds of hate and
jealousy that happened around you if you
popping off and all that stuff and I
always remove I'm so grateful that most
of the time I remove myself from that
and focused on my work cuz you gave me
hope to do that so I thank you for that
and I was very grateful I had that
moment man it's huge
that's huge no more Europe these
relationships are everything to me
you're a great [ __ ] young man I hate
I'm very proud of you I was very proud
when I saw you I did not hesitate I'm
putting on the podcasting because I know
what you've gone through and you're a
real student of the game where can
people find you you can find me a real
mo Amer
check out my special on Netflix in town
of the vagabond very very proud of that
it's like my life's work into that baby
and the next one we're working on but
real mo Amer on all platforms someway
don't be in the next couple weeks I'm
going to DC and beat the Improv great
city and I'ma be at the improv in Miami
I'm also going to I think New Jersey and
New Brunswick every action yeah stress
factory and then I'm doing doing Detroit
just several dates I'm doing Detroit I'm
doing Cobbs full tour I got the new hour
it's all brand new material so I'm torn
in that right now and then I'm filming a
TV show and this this fall man season
two around me so I'm very very excited
about that man [ __ ] very proud of you
proud of you too I love you back so
anytime you love you guys you're always
welcome
do not forget I'm in New Orleans at the
Fillmore theater next Friday night and
then Saturday we're at the Tabernacle
[ __ ] theta in ATL I'm
and by what's-her-name's chicken
Tabernacle is the best best venues
fathers makes an amazing I'm going over
to Gladys Knight's oh yes [ __ ] check
online for a few minutes I love Atlanta
I love New Orleans yes sir so I'll see
you [ __ ] down there in a few
weeks real quick here I just want to
[ __ ] give a shout out to the sponsors
of life I'll let you [ __ ] take
off do not forget CBB Lyon no more bye
and CBD and a [ __ ] liquor store from
now on you're gonna see BD Lyon calm and
that's where you get the best CBD around
they make CBD products from start to
finish they have you covered it comes in
a vapor it comes in cartridges it comes
in a shadow and not only that if you're
not into smoking they got tremendous
gummies strawberry raspberry orange and
they got a [ __ ] tension you put under
your tongue I get twenty five hundred
milligrams I put two of those shots
under my tongue before I go to bed at
night and next morning I'm in [ __ ]
Muay Thai class with a bunch of
twenty-year-old is that's what it does
for me
these products are [ __ ] to clean
Bobby and then I like the fakes that you
see at all these [ __ ] liquor stores
and [ __ ] [ __ ] places this is what
I'm talking about and CBD Lyon is what
you've been waiting for if you have a
doubt go to CBB line comm and check out
that third-party test results you're
gonna [ __ ] drool and right now the
church family gets 20% at checkout when
you press code Church that CBD Lyon comm
pressing code Church and I'm gonna give
you 20% off delivered right to your
[ __ ] house all right CBD Lyon
calm the best CBD out there in the
market number two sub is coming and let
me tell you something there's nothing
better than taking a nice little morning
[ __ ] okay a little cup of coffee this is
by the way this is my favorite advertise
oh my god
I own all that this is Arabs and Muslims
has all we've been doing for since the
be it like we wash our hands you don't
[ __ ] comprehend that
we don't comprehend in toilet paper
regular people see a bottle of water
Arab see potential you know what I mean
I can use this [ __ ] bottled water
wash my ass cuz it's better than if you
don't have pushy in your life if you
don't have touchy you're gonna be [ __ ]
doomed
that's how germs start that's how
hemorrhoids start and that's how stink
starts you don't want to stink cuz
wiping his growth would you clean dirty
crusty dishes with dry paper what if a
bird pooped on you toilet paper wet
wipes are ruining the [ __ ]
environment did you know the average
person uses 57 sheets a toilet paper a
[ __ ] day you knobbly trees they gotta
kill for you to wipe your [ __ ] stinky
ass and it requires $37 37 gallons of
water the bathroom is a modern day
self-care oasis right now I could take
care you understand me but days are back
wiping your butt with dry toilet paper
don't remove all this [ __ ] thankfully
there's this new sleek bidet attachment
that clips onto your existing toilet and
it sprays your [ __ ] muffle clean with
fresh water it's called tushy and it's
the best thing you could do for yourself
and for your filthy little [ __ ]
[ __ ] so she sprays directly into your
ass and removes poop and toilet paper
and [ __ ] cat hair completely so yards
sitting on back tearing that leaves some
nasty things like yeast infections UTIs
and itchy ass holes and then you gotta
[ __ ] scratch your ass to snip your
finger [ __ ] that [ __ ]
I agree not let's not talk about skid
marks here nasty [ __ ] nasty
mother sorry yet the [ __ ] gyms the
days are common in the rest of the world
like my friend sent over here a bidet
saves your money on toilet paper and you
still have little paper to pat dry but
the amount is negligible won't clog your
[ __ ] toilet until she sprays your ass
with fresh [ __ ] water that's not
toilet water let's recycle until she
connects to the water supply behind your
toilet to spray your dirty parts with
clean fresh water it's the same water
you brush your teeth with right now
until she's gonna give you a 10% off
your order they got a Father's Day
bundle that includes the tissue birthday
to upgrade your porcelain Thrones for a
king they got bamboo bump tiles made of
100% bamboo fibers and because they got
tushy travel because dad's on the go
probably gotta [ __ ] go so you give
them anywhere in any way you need to
beat yeah so clean - she'll be there
plus they're throwing and they asked me
about my butt hole t-shirt all right you
know you got a sense of humor when you
wear one of these shirts from tushy all
these bundles together are a hundred and
twenty-five dollars but forget about
that till she start at $69 and it'll
change your life go to touch it hello -
she's calm right now that's hello - she
Preston Church and get 10% off your
[ __ ] order I want to thank
tushie
I want to thank CBD lines not coming I'm
gonna give a quick shout out the roots
of fights they always send me a nice
shirt every month they send me something
nice roots or fight and I never give
them any love if you like it boxing
we're sports we're going to roots a
fight right now
and look at the fine selection of
t-shirts on what not that they have and
that's it and that's that I want to
thank my man morale man I want to thank
the [ __ ] but most importantly I
want to thank you [ __ ] for
always having my back that's it and
that's that see you at the Fillmore in
New Orleans or see you at the [ __ ]
tam-tam Tabernacle Maneka in Atlanta
Georgia besides that
see you Monday morning get ready a
[ __ ] Rock [ __ ] have a great
weekend I love you and stay black kick
this [ __ ] mealy